here we are uh at Eagle Pass uh and
we're going to be uh meeting with uh uh
the sort of major the major officials so
Elon Musk our renaissance man of the day
who's saving free speech on Twitter and
sending us to Mars and building Teslas
and everything else he decided all right
I'll also take my phone and go to the
Mexican border here he is in Eagle Pass
Texas doing a live stream on Twitter
explaining what the hell is going on
down
there yeah so here we are uh at Eagle
pass uh and we're going to be uh meeting
with uh uh the sort of major the major
officials uh uh and law enforcement are
responsible for the water and um and
just hear it directly from them and see
it see exactly what's going on uh for
yourself so so basically we're seeing um
unpressed this the oldtime highs um and
increasing and spreading it's not in
just one area it's it's not just like
it's just one city or one town not even
one State anymore you know it's not
we're talking about New York today but
Chicago you're hearing it there La
Denver there's all these other places
where it's just spreading just continues
to get bubbling up do you think Elon
Musk might have better things to do with
this time maybe not better maybe that's
not the right word it's important what
he's doing but do you think that when
Elon Musk woke up a couple weeks ago and
was looking at his calendar for the
month he thought oh I'll just head down
to the border and deal with that no he
wanted to do all of the other absolute
truly incredible things that he's doing
but we need more people to shed light on
this right we need more people to show
us something that's true and give us an
honest assessment of what's going on
here take a look at this image this is
Elon at the border and look those are
that's hundreds easily I don't know how
far the picture goes out of frame of
people that are just standing there
waiting to get in and guess what they're
basically all going to get in I thought
I'd show you some numbers here and
here's where I can give Trump a little
credit uh just like I did a moment ago
this is data from the the US Customs and
Border Patrol of total migrant
encounters so 17 18 and 19 now these are
the years that Trump was president and
even 20 you had 310 404 859 and
45,000 uh people uh at the border right
so just by the nature whether the Border
was porous or not just by Trump saying
hey you can't come in less people came
then Biden becomes president and look
what happens to the numbers 1.66 million
in Biden's first year 2.21 million in
Biden second year and year to date this
year 1.8 million so we will obviously
eclipse last year's numbers on that so
the point is that when you can where you
can criticize Trump is that he didn't
get the wall done and by the way the
Democrats were never going to let him
get the wall done and everything else
but this is where you have to be a
better negotiator you have to be a
better executive and all that Mexico was
never going to pay for it but his
rhetoric alone does matter when when a
republican gets there and says you can't
come people hear that across the world
but when a Democrat gets there and like
well the border is kind of open and we
don't know nobody's illegal and
everybody's welcome and all that stuff
the very nature of the rhetoric allows
people to come and then they show up and
they go boy that border doesn't look too
Clos and there's a nice man in a in a
United States security outfit and he's
going to open up the door for me do we
have to tip these
people